good morning Hank it's Tuesday and I
decided to come out oh he's here it's a
reunion spectacular I mean I look like
the hobo version of you Hank and I are
gonna play a game today it's called got
it uh we I saw it on Tick Tock now
YouTube is just uh tick tocks but
horizontal so we're gonna do the game
the rules are we both say a word and
then we find the intersection between
those two words until we say the same
word I just remembered something
important what you can only get pizza
the stuff for a few more days at
pizzamous.com got it one two three one
two three Beach
[Music]
all right Bud one two three motion
oh was there a picnic in the ocean that
happens all the time Hank you do it on a
blanket at the beach
it's an ocean picnic got it one two
three life raft yes
John can we start with two word phrases
or is that too no definitely not you
gotta go with the word one two three
Universal Health Care
what that's three words
no no it's to it most and I think it
could be hyphenated in a pinch got it
one two three dead one two three
Hospital
oh have you been following the cheating
scandals in the world oh yeah oh my God
have you been following the cheating
scandals like I have in the world of the
poker no professional fishing oh yeah no
one trusts anyone anymore and they think
that they could just get away with
whatever I'm starting to think that the
only thing worse than institutions is a
lack of Institutions got it one two
three oxygen
all right I got it I bet you do I don't
one two three hydrogen oh dang it I get
that that makes a lot of sense
I got one okay one two three chemistry
better yours is better we have moved to
meet Hanks needs to be in the shade
one two three electricity oh dang it why
are you sticking with chemicals I'm
trying to move us on how do I know that
helium was involved there was definitely
electricity involved that's why it blew
out I didn't know that was electricity
well there must have been an initial
spark how do we get out of chemistry and
into like Shakespeare or Jane Austen
Tony Morrison novels got it got it one
two three lightning
a lightning party is more fun for me
than helium electricity okay lightning
and party three two one indoors oh that
is what you should do if there's a
lightning and there's a party you do it
indoors
I've got it but for the record I I'm
going with what I think you're gonna say
not with what I think is the right
answer
got it then I'll say what I think I'm
gonna say three two one Putt-Putt which
is outside but I knew I knew that that
was the only don't you watch Brooks Holt
videos I knew that was the only golf
related term that might be vaguely
indoors that you knew hey leave us ideas
for what we should do in our last three
Pizza Miss videos we got it I got it in
the com I don't have my Thursday video
that's true and you shouldn't have your
Friday video because your Friday video
should be pizzamist.com pizzamist.com if
you don't get this piece of his shirt
right now it will be gone forever yeah
or at least until we make a throw
blanket out of it next year John I'll
see you tomorrow I feel like we're going
to continue to see each other right now
do you have a pizza Miss dad joke before
we go
I have one you know Pete Davidson and
Kim Kardashian broke up
did you hear about it
no pizza pizza mess
pizzamass.com nice